[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I am very glad to be with dr.
John McWhorter professor at Columbia
University in English he is a specialist
in linguistics his particular focus is
Creole languages and American history do
I have that right John you could say
that American Studies and Creole
languages and language contact in
general and language change yeah
wonderful well thank you for joining me
I do hope at some point we get to talk
about linguistics and Creole languages
it is an absolutely fascinating topic at
the moment though I think what is taking
place in the Republic is of great
importance and I know you feel the same
way and so we are going to focus on that
today if that's all right by you that
works for me all right great so let me
lay this out a little bit for you I am I
am feeling a bit called at the moment by
what is taking place and I think the
urgency of it is is quite great are you
also feeling called is that a fair
assessment yeah I certainly am being
called in terms of suddenly the the
number of emails and tweets and various
kinds of Facebook messages I'm getting
but yeah a moment has come when
something that's been kind of burbling
since the year 2013 is about when there
was a real sea change has really come to
a head and left a lot of people who
would consider themselves liberal or
even leftists curious as to what this
new extreme prosecutorial strain of the
left is that now actually seems to be
making its way into mainstream
institutions and so I think there are
many of us whose work and thoughts have
been relevant to that over the past six
or seven years where suddenly over the
past three weeks it seems like it's a
time when we're needed or that we need
to say something it's felt almost like a
burden to me because things are having
so quickly that it's hard to have a
large picture idea that you can imagine
standing the test of time but I have to
get over the idea that everything you
say is gonna stand the test of time or
you know sound like Will Durant but yes
this is this is a tough time it's a
tough time and I know that there's also
just the fact that we're walking a
Razors Edge of sorts and one doesn't
want to say something that one discovers
is taken the wrong way and that makes
things worse so that's a problem I think
probably we're both facing in this
circumstance but in any case I think you
and I have never met in person but I
think we have established a rapport
online in the way that happens it's a
very odd process but I think we trust
each other and what I would suggest is
for this conversation to be maximally
useful that we suspend all rules of
politeness in other words I would like
you to be absolutely as direct with me
as you think is helpful and I promise
you I will not be thin-skinned even if
the corrections of my perspective are
substantial and I will do the same and
in so doing we can model how a
conversation about race which is
unavoidably going to be at the center of
what we talk about might sound and maybe
people can get a sense of an alternative
to the dialogue that we see unfolding on
on the streets of the u.s. at this
moment okay that makes sense I want to
say beforehand though and this is gonna
seem trivial that for those of you who
are watching this as well as listening
my appearance is probably quite
unpleasant and it's because I am in a
rustic cabin not by myself and not
filling envelopes with anything but I am
up far away not in the view of too many
human beings other than my children I
have Kovan hair
I have not styled it today I haven't
shaven I'm wearing the wrong glasses so
letting you know I know what this looks
like this is not how I look but in any
case let us proceed to weightier matters
well you know what you look great but
you've also landed in the right place
because my audience is thoroughly used
to Cova dare I have had kovat hair from
the start before anyone had heard of
kovat night sense though anyway by
comparison and in absolute terms here
you're just fine so okay what is going
on in the Republic I have the sense that
a story I lived in 2017 at a tiny
college in the northwest corner of the
country has suddenly spilled over and
it's now in every major city in the u.s.
yeah and it's funny the what happened to
you outside of your office what we can
now see on video it's been fashionable
to say that that frame of mind was just
a bunch of crazy kids among people who
some people I think really do think that
and other people haven't wanted to allow
that that kind of view is becoming
dominant probably because a lot of the
people who are inclined to dismiss that
as a lot of crazy kids are people who
are inclined to let it pass in general
and often aren't aware that there's a
part of those people and then themselves
but the question is why has it become
what I almost can't let come out of my
mouth it's becoming a mainstream
sentiment this unreasoning form of
leftism where language is misused in
ways that seem so Stalinist and
Orwellian that it's almost like a
cartoon and yet the people are standing
there actually taking themselves
seriously and having no idea that what
they're doing is recapitulating some of
the most futile and useless
socio-political currents in history it's
really an interesting cocktail because
you even wonder George Floyd what
happened to him was absolutely
unjustifiable and yet the fact is that
similarly absolutely unjustifiable
things happen to black men and I should
say men in general not to mention women
in the United States practically every
day why that particular person why did
that bring this out to the extent that
it did and we've seen this kind of
ideology brought out by cop killings
before
an iconic time was with Trayvon Martin
when social media as we know it was
relatively new and it brought out a
great many white people as well that was
new amadou diallo in 1998 was one thing
if I might was another it was the same
with Ferguson here though you know bread
and I'm just I'm going by the seat of my
pants here but I think that we're
dealing currently with how social
history can be confounding and often
random the butterfly flaps some of this
I think and this is not to minimize how
important it is that we reform the cops
it's absolutely important but I think
that the virus had something to do with
the heat of the response here I think a
lot of people were really tired of being
trapped inside were really tired of the
muzzled feeling that we've all had since
the middle of March and the weather
starts to get better and that man was
murdered at a particular meteorological
time and I think a lot of people and
when I say this I don't just mean black
rioters I mean everybody you see in
these protests wanted a reason to get
outside I don't think it was deliberate
I don't think they were being cynical
but I think there was a joy in being
able to be with other people to express
some passion and to get outside and so
to tell you the truth if that leads to
cop reform I say fine that's the way
history works but nevertheless it did
bring out this particular kind of person
with a particular kind of message and we
now have a particular kind of social
media and we have a particular president
that doesn't help either we have a truly
repulsive [ __ ] as a president who makes
a lot of people very very upset and
justifiably and so after 19th in 1960
after 2016 I imagine we were primed for
something like this anyway so I think
that that's why all of a sudden this
hard unreasoning Orwellian social
justice warrior left of the kind that
was telling you you were saying quote
unquote some racist [ __ ] a few years ago
is now dominating the op-ed pages and
toppling literary committees and making
people resign you know with all of it
involving
people who know full well that they're
being bullshitted actually bowing down
to this kind of rhetoric because it's so
frightening and yeah it's it's hard to
take in well we have our work cut out
for us I see a lot in what you've said
that I agree with but I think I'm far
more worried than it sounds like you are
about what's going to come out of this
for a couple reasons
and I should say one of the things I
think I've never spoken about this
publicly but one of the things that
happened is evergreen came apart was it
was graffiti about me all over the place
and posters and there was a certain
amount of trayvon martin stuff hurled at
me as if i was george zimmerman or
something like that and i think the
reason that this matters is that it just
tells you how preposterous the claims
can be and still pass muster in in the
movement and so you say people know
they're being bullshitted a few do and i
think they start out knowing that but
that there's an insidious process here
in which people feel jeopardized
understandably they make concessions
that are initially small and then they
are marched in the direction of
gargantuan falsehoods that they then
have to convince themselves of in order
to sleep at night and so it it's a kind
of spreading process the reason that so
many people got wrong what was going on
on college campuses was that they
thought it was a college phenomenon they
thought kids protest and part of growing
up and that's never what this was that's
an element of it it's why we've got
there first but this is I think a
contagious madness and the worst part of
this contagious madness is that because
it is focused on a false narrative and I
really believe the narrative is false it
is obscuring the true narrative that
actually explains the frustration and so
in what says well let's start this way I
believe that what's going on
is a couple things you're right about
kovat 19 there's an element I would add
which is that kovat 19 pulled the rug
out from under the economy as far as
working people go and so the you know
the sort of Occupy sentiment that the
system is rigged and that that haunts
some of us more than others is now this
is an Occupy 2.0 phenomenon that we're
seeing with a black lives matter
phenomenon right so people who've lost
their jobs discovered that their jobs
were garbage to begin with you know in
the Cova 19 situation are looking
forward and realizing that they are
their slice of the pie isn't very large
and they're spilling into the streets so
the frustration I think is quite real
and understandable yeah absolutely
understandable but I would argue that
policing and in particular brutal
policing and militarized policing are a
symptom of an economic system that is
actually rigged in ways that are obvious
sometimes and in ways that are subtle in
others in other places but that in
effect we are now having a battle about
policing that makes no sense
yes policing needs to be reformed this
is clear but you can't certainly a
discussion in which police reform is
being blurred with the concept of you
know eliminating the police there's no
conversation to be had even if there was
some way to eliminate the police you
certainly can't start there
so we're having a frustratingly empty
conversation and this is causing the
people who are maybe not as aware of the
unfairness in our system and the rigna
of our system it's causing them to feel
emboldened because they're seeing
arguments that don't add up and their
sense as well as to shut this down right
so they're missing the fact that the
energy behind the protest is the result
of something a very natural process and
a real something yeah a very real
something people have a right to be
frustrated now let's just March right
the fire was George Floyd murdered yes
what Derek Chauvin did to him was
utterly unnecessary I mean George Floyd
was very intoxicated he was acting up I
find it very difficult to see from the
videos whether or not he was resisting
arrest if anything he seems to have been
in a passive sort of way he needed to be
put into a police car and taken
somewhere and you know disciplined find
or something for somebody to put you
know the knee on his neck and he's
pleading for his life yeah I would call
that of murder and I'm not one for
extreme rhetoric what I think needs to
be brought into it though is that Tony
timppa was murdered four years before
with a knee into his back with the same
pleading for his life equally
unjustified recorded the cops got off
the same thing and Timbo was white we're
not supposed to talk about that and of
course more white men are murdered that
way than black men and sometimes women
you're supposed to talk about the fact
that black people are killed by cops
disproportionately to our numbers in the
population but then again you can also
say that poverty makes you more likely
to encounter the cops and black people
are disproportionately likely to be poor
for unpardonable reasons that like we're
talking about there are larger issues
here that people are justifiably upset
about too many black people are poor but
as it turns out it's almost in the
numbers on this are almost cosmically
consonant in that there are black people
are 2.5 times more likely to be poor and
2.5 times more likely to be killed by
cops I don't think that's an accident
now I didn't make up those figures so
what that means is that one may despise
the cops but to say that George Floyd
was murdered because he was black as
tempting as it is to think that given
that that's the film that we're gonna
see again and again and again it's very
tempting
but it's not an accurate depiction of
what actually happens and we're in a
technological moment where it's really
easy to see the larger picture The
Washington Post has done a project that
tells you exactly who's been killed year
by year by year and under exactly which
conditions at the push of a button you
could have done that ten years ago and
yet we're being foisted with a certain
error so yes I would say that George
Floyd was murdered but the problem is
that to say that it was because of his
black skin did tracks from solutions to
America's problems that would float all
boats to use a metaphor that's gone kind
of stain and what worries me about all
of this is that as I've written often
we're dealing not with the political
ideology but with something that an
anthropologist would recognize as
religion and it's easy to hear me say
that and think that I'm trying to make a
rhetorical point I don't mean like a
religion it is a religion the way that
you understand how these people operate
is to actually imagine how you would
interact with a Mormon who you were
trying to convince that Joseph Smith
didn't dig up tablets in the backyard
and again not rhetoric folks exactly
that it's the same frame of much it's
just that our language doesn't happen to
apply the label religion to the kinds of
ideology that we've seen over about the
past ten years and so the problem is
that the tenets of this religion that
dominates is that to be against racism
trumped literally everything else there
are ranked priorities and being against
racism and we have to talk about what
that is but being against racism is
everything to the point that you allow
yourself not to make any logical sense
and so you must be against racism and so
the George Floyd must have been murdered
because he was black and there's no
questions asked and you cannot have any
kind of dialogue with a person of color
about racism if you have any kind of
dialogue with them if you question
anything that they say such as you do
you are a racist and they're no
questions to be asked and I've seen that
even in my own academic work
where you know as a much more naive
person I've tried to be an empiricist
about things and been savaged and not
quite understood it until nowadays I
realized wait a minute I was dealing
with parishioners it was the proto
versions of these things late 90s the
Oakland School Board tries to address
black kids lagging rates of scholastic
performance by treating black English as
a different language and bringing in
translation exercises and dialect books
there's very little evidence that that
sort of thing works and an awful lot of
evidence that certain kinds of you know
race neutral reading pedagogy techniques
really do help poor kids from bookless
homes ie for black kids I tried to talk
about that kind of thing and I was
ripped a new one by countless black and
white linguists and educators and I'd
say but look what you're proposing
doesn't work as well as other things
like English is not a separate language
nobody thought that back when Black
English was a lot less like standard
English than it is now I realized now
who's the religion it's not that this
religion emerged somewhere in nineteen
2013 I wasn't prioritizing anti racism
you talk about my Creole languages
Creole languages are fascinating because
what happens is that language is broken
down into a pigeon which is not a
language at all and then it's built back
up into a brand new language out of what
ones who are fragments that's really
neat there's a strain in Creole studies
and it's exactly what what we're talking
about that insists that Creole languages
didn't come from pigeons because pigeons
are not real language Creole languages
are just mixtures and it has nothing to
do with anybody ever having started with
a pidgin and the thing is every language
in the world is a mixture Creoles are
different from just mixed languages it
would be like claiming that um every
single creature in the world that the
analogy is gonna go off the rails
is some kind of hybrid and so it's it's
as if lynn margulis was right about
everything everything is about
combination there's no such thing as
there having been really simpler
creatures in the Precambrian the idea is
that the I'm going to throw something up
the Ediacaran creatures are as
flex as Jaguars and people there's just
there's no difference that's what's
going on in Creole studies and if you
insist that no these are languages that
are born again it's like sea monkeys
first I look like that they've built out
of little eggs and they come again
you're a racist and yes that's been
aimed at me and of course they're about
three and a half people in Creole
studies who insist on this loudly and
explicitly almost everybody else in the
field doesn't want to get mauled by them
and so they decide that they're agnostic
about the matter they say I don't really
care how Creole languages form as if
that isn't the fundamental thing that
you wish to know when you're studying
languages where do they come from and
out were they born it's like a biologist
saying oh I don't care about the DNA I
don't care how walruses are related to
salamanders I don't I'm agnostic about
that I have other things to do that
passes for actual coherent thought in
linguistics in my little area of
linguistics because you don't want to
say that black people ever didn't learn
a language well even if they were slaves
on a plantation where no one taught it
do them because of anti racism that's
what we're up against oh I see what you
mean that it can take over everything
but I always thought okay it's not just
college students it's also college
professors it's certain college town
realms but it's not gonna take over the
world
maybe up in naive well I again agree
with a ton of what you say this is a
religion we are seeing exactly what
you're talking about in biology as well
we're having a fight over whether sex is
real that is absurd because this
couldn't possibly be clearer right yeah
I know it's happening everywhere so that
tells you how insidious it is because
almost everybody in my field knows
better and yet most are quiet or they're
hedging because they don't want to get
Mol or the mob right so but here's the
problem I have believed that George
Floyd was murdered I don't think that's
necessarily what happened at this point
and I think the problem is that that is
taking on religious momentum and so if I
can if you'll give me the opportunity to
scare you a little bit that's okay let
me paint a different picture I would
love to know yeah okay
what I saw on Vidya what I know that I
saw is a miscarriage of justice a
massive one what I don't know is enough
about policing about drugs and
physiology about heart attacks to know
exactly what I saw I certainly don't
know that what I saw was racist for
exactly the Tony timba point that you
make that you know what we saw was that
the video was running on a case that
matches people's priors and so it got
broadcast and caught on and that was
about race but we don't know whether you
know let's say that Derek Chauvin did
murder George Floyd we don't know if it
would have been equally likely had he
been a white guy you can't know but
here's the thing that troubles me even
more at this point is there is reason to
believe that that George Floyd saying
that he could not breathe was occurring
before he was ever on the ground and
that he was having a heart attack
there's some evidence to this effect we
know from his autopsy that there were a
very potent combination of drugs in his
system
Faton all I believe methamphetamine we
know that the technique that Derek
Chauvin was using is a technique that is
officially sanctioned under some
circumstances and I think we know that
there was a discussion about whether or
not George Floyd was in a state and I've
now forgotten I can almost remember the
acronym for the state II XD s maybe that
required some kind of restraint to
prevent him from injuring himself or
others so here's the question it is
possible that what happened there as
egregious as it was fit with police
policy that the police policy is what is
in error and it is the police policy
that caused the miscarriage of justice
and while it's hard for me to imagine
that Derek Chauvin is a good guy because
he's obviously callous enough to have
ignored this man's pleading and
insistence that he couldn't breathe to
the point so they had a record of
being a very callous policeman before
but anyway right right so there's
evidence of that so this about what I'm
what I'm really getting at is our system
absolutely depends on the fact that we
do not convict people unless there has
been due process and yet we are now
speaking about Derek Chauvin as if we
all know that a murder took place and
that's certainly something you could see
something on video that would tell you
almost beyond a reasonable doubt that
somebody had been murdered but I don't
think what we saw on video tells us that
because there's too much stuff that most
of us don't know anything about like how
do these drugs affect you what is the
police policy in Minneapolis we don't
know any of those facts so so anyway
here's my concern is it possible for
Derek children to get a fair trial
in in the modern era at this arm not in
the public sphere like I think that it's
quite possible and possibly to possible
that he get off because of not only the
facts of the case but certain things
entrenched in the cops and the unions
and how trial works he could get off
because a very small number of people
look at the sorts of things you're
looking at and realized that he does not
deserve to be called a murderer
if English had a more explicit
subjunctive I'd use it there that he did
not deserve maybe he did but maybe he
didn't I'm not remotely offended at your
saying that maybe he didn't we don't
know like I'll even give you something
watching the tape there are two things
that strike me and one is that the Asian
one whose name I forget is just sitting
there watching and what we're supposed
to think is that he's this barbarian but
how many barbarians like that are there
who really would just stand there and
I've been told a part of it is that he
actually is essentially a trainee at
that point and he's supposed to be
different but still if somebody is down
there expiring on the basis of a clearly
murderous mood would he really be just
standing there and he
been giving an insouciant look into a
cellphone camera I've wondered and also
you're not supposed to say this and I've
never watched somebody die I don't know
but it's my intuition and I've had a few
other people secretly write to me but
they wonder he doesn't sound like he's
asphyxiated he keeps on saying I can't
breathe
but it's so clear it's so loud he keeps
saying oh man now I don't I've never
heard anybody it's fix e8 I may be
really missing something but you imagine
some sort of constriction and from the
sound the first time I heard this before
I knew it was gonna be a big deal I
thought it's terrible that he died but
when he's saying I can't breathe I hate
to admit it but it almost sounded like a
quote it's almost like he was he
remembered what Eric garner said and I'm
not saying that he's he's trying to do a
show or that he was happy but he doesn't
sound like he can't breathe now I say
that out of naivete I have never had my
knee on anybody's neck nobody's afraid
of their knee on mine but I am open I'm
wondering whether the death was due not
only to that pressure but to the fact
that he had other things inside of him
he couldn't have been a healthy man
based on what we've heard and he doesn't
deserve it but can you get a fair trial
in society no and so for what we'll see
based on the anti-racist imperative is
that he absolutely has to be guilty and
so for example Darren Walker and Mike
Brown the facts make it clear including
the black people who watch this who
often recanted their original testimony
which they made because they were afraid
of being jumped by the narrative but he
killed Mike Brown because Mike Brown
kept coming at him and he was afraid he
can have a whole discussion about why he
couldn't have shot him in the knee etc
you hear that the cops are trained to
shoot to kill after a certain point we
don't the territory that again I don't
really have my bearing in but he didn't
just shoot the guy with his hands up it
isn't true and yet you know there's a
The New Yorker does a profile of Darren
Walker that makes him sound like the
devil spawn anyway because he doesn't
know the narrative 101 and so you know
he's what we must get rid of and then
today anybody who admits that Mike Brown
wasn't killed that way and a lot of
people just like to pretend
John for the legend is printed on some
level that happened you just know
there's gonna be a film we're at the
point where Mike Brown is shot
everything goes into blurry and there's
strobe lights and their various
perspectives and all of a sudden that's
gonna be Rashomon as if there are many
different perspectives and the director
is gonna give interviews saying they
wanted to give everybody their say it's
not gonna just show what happened and
that's symbolic of the consciousness but
also nowadays you deflect so if you
don't want to talk about the Mike Brown
facts we talk about the fact that he was
laying on the street for four hours and
that's unjust I've heard people wax
eloquent about that to the degree that
people were talking about this is
perfectly done in with his hands up six
years ago no Chauvin will never be able
to raise his head in public again it's
the same thing with George Zimmerman
Zimmerman's story is quite different
from what we were told and yet his life
is ruined because these people are
needed as symbols in this narrative they
are they're Judas's and this is the kind
of thinking that we're encouraged to do
this is to watch this with people who
otherwise think normally and empirically
it's a religious frame of mind this is
exactly what I'm worried about so you
say that he will never get a fair trial
in the court of public opinion which I
agree I also don't think he can get a
fair trial in a courtroom
at this point because given the way we
are all connected it will be I think
impossible to find a jury that will not
be aware that a verdict that does not
reflect public opinion in this case will
result in an eruption of anger that yeah
I mean it's it's Rodney King times a
thousand and so
here's the reason I find this so
terrifying is that I believe some kind
of possibly unprecedented trolley
problem is unfolding in this case and
that everybody will quietly calculate to
themselves maybe not even in their
conscious mind but somewhere that in
fact irrespective of what the facts are
in the case and you know let's say that
George Floyd had a heart attack was
highly likely to die and that the knee
on the neck as egregious as it was it
was a minor factor in his death right
that would obviously be a very important
fact in a case were this not racially
charged and were there no protests in
the streets but if the system concludes
that it must convict him then this
effectively is us participating in a
witch-hunt now I'm not saying that he's
not guilty of murder I think it's likely
he is guilty of murder but I don't know
that he's guilty of murder yet and my
sense is that we have already marked so
far down this road we are already now
speaking as if we can all agree that
he's guilty of murder here the doubt
exists where the question of race is
that we are unwittingly participating in
a dangerous religious exercise even
those of us who wish to resist doing
that at all costs
you know what's alarming there is that
what you're saying is that this is going
to go beyond people being unable to get
justice in the rarefied world of the
college campus where one wonders whether
that could change within our lifetimes
but it's going to be in actual courts of
law about matters having to do with
physical life and death and yes that's
alarming especially because you know
there is this critical race theory
within legal theory the idea being that
we think not always of individuals but
of general stories and as pretty as that
sounds that's the sort of thing that
leads to the idea that even if on some
technical level this could even you
could even think of it as
philosophically profound on some
technical level if it turns out the
stove and it
kill George Floyd if it does that he did
on some other level on some narrative
level because this has been happening to
us forever and although most of the
people on that hypothetical jury
probably don't read critical race theory
that way of thinking is percolating into
the general consciousness and what might
be alarming is that it's no longer just
people with PhDs and the equivalent its
beginning not to be just people who read
The New Yorker and listen to NPR it's
beginning to just be folks that is um
that is alarming if that is where we're
going and the verdict on Chauvin I don't
know that they say show then and show
that I'm gonna say Shoven Chauvin could
be seen as a bellwether of that yes that
that is true that this time he doesn't
get off despite the fact that the facts
are muddy and that even civilians like
us can see yeah that is alarming and so
then what happens breath where are we
going oh my goodness I'm afraid if we
are not very careful that we are staring
at the uninvented of the Republic and
I'm not sure that that that idea that
thought that possibility properly
horrifies people because as flawed as
this Republic is it's uninvent is going
to be an absolute disaster and I think
frankly this is something that is more
easily seen by people outside the US and
I've had contact with quite a number who
are frightened at what they are seeing
unfold even though they know our system
is unfair but the prospect of the u.s.
failing is is a dangerous one for the
world so there's a lot riding on this as
to your point about what is potentially
going to unfold in courtrooms given the
rhetoric and given how aggressive the
campaign is that is causing people to
adopt this critical race theory now most
of them don't know that that's what
they're adopting and I should also say
everything that you don't no longer
write you're just you're active in it
and you don't know where it came from or
what it actually means I also should say
my understanding
the critical race theory was born as an
honorable investigation of biases inside
courtrooms and then it sort of morphed
into this monster but but in any case
I'm concerned that we are actually much
closer to the the place that you suggest
we might be headed with respect to
courtrooms because in light of the
beliefs that are being now commonly
expressed without the ability to
disagree with them there is certain to
be a two-tiered expression of due
process in a courtroom in other words
those who are understood to be suffering
from a history of oppression will
experience a bias in their favor and
those who were understood to be part of
the race that has been perpetrating the
oppression will face a very different
standard now the really difficult part
about this is that there is some truth
to the fact that the reverse of that
situation has existed in courts since
the Republic was founded right so black
people have had a raw deal not only
economically for reasons I'd love to get
back to if there's time and if not this
time we'll do it in a future
conversation but the system has been
unfair and it has been two-tiered but we
are actually now involved in a public
discussion in which instead of ending
oppression which has been the the goal
since the civil rights movement we are
actually talking about turning the
tables of oppression turning the tables
and creating the inversion of the values
that the nation is founded on and that
is a very dangerous idea it is it is
bound to be unstable and we will all
suffer from it bound to be unstable of
course the people who are hoping that
this really takes over are under the
impression that once we accomplish this
anti-racist goal that everything would
be ok I get the feeling they think it
wouldn't be unstable
I think that what's happened before has
been unstable in the rhetoric would be
because you know you you adopt what
James Baldwin didn't exactly mean that
white people's identity depends on their
being black people below that white
people are deeply deeply unstable
psychologically because of their
feelings about black people and because
of racism and they need to face it in
order to be whole etc so the idea would
be that once we get beyond this then
everything would be alright what they
don't understand is that they would be
busting everything down based upon an
uncompromising kind of ideology that
could never create a true consensus and
we'd only be on to worse things and
there's so much that would be wrong with
that society i i probably lack a little
bit of imagination i'm not i'm not
looking at this as cleanly as you are i
suspect into my tendency is to think
that this is a pendulum shift that
things tend to go too far and then
things come back to a healthy middle
that's even happened with race ideology
you could have watched the sorts of
things people were saying in the late
60s you know dashikis and black power
and i rather in coherent ideology black
panthers doing some violent things some
good things as one's supposed to say
about the black panthers but the violent
aspect as well and you might have
thought that something was really
something really scary was going on as
one would have thought in 1968 in
general all and nevertheless by 1980 all
those things had been tempered some what
society had been changed attitudes on
race were profoundly different even
under ronald reagan than they had been
under Lyndon Johnson but now here we are
with another kind of pendulum shift
unthinking where if perhaps there is an
articulate enough push back against the
extremes here and articulate means
partly putting it in a way that people
beyond academia can understand maybe we
can come to a sort of liberal slash
leftist consensus that isn't based on
refusing to face facts that isn't based
on recapitulating a religious kind of
thinking that Martin Luther would have
recognized which
I know this insults some religious
people when I put it this way but which
many of us feel that we have moved
forward from many of us find it a
forward idea to not base any of our
cognition to the extent that we know it
on suspension of disbelief many of us
think of that as progress I would be
fake if I did not say that I do I'm
sorry I'm sorry to those whom that seems
to insult but I have to be honest and to
go back to having this kind of mental
cocoon where you are encouraged to stop
thought and thought that that makes you
a more only advance person that is
frightening I wonder though right you
know it can't be just books it can't be
just podcasts what about a documentary
moving that here there needs to be good
90-minute documentary that really gets
across what's wrong with this and you
know probably not next week it doesn't
need to be you know during our
conversation about George Floyd but
there needs to be a statement against
this that people can actually watch and
it actually makes people think I think
it can be pushed back against partly
because that's one of my matey A's but
you think that it could possibly just
topple the United States I do I think we
might be looking at well let's put it
this way I think what I'm seeing in the
street reminds me far too much of maoism
and that if you attempt a Maoist
takeover in the US you will get a civil
war so I am very concerned that we are
much closer to a brink that frankly I
think we all know is out there somewhere
but then you worry that do you remember
that right-wing crazies are gonna come
gunning well here's the I'm hesitant to
say right-wing crazies because what I
think the problem is I full well
understand looking at people tearing
apart cities saying things that make no
sense
you know claiming that on inventing the
police that you know abolishing them
would be progress
that there unfortunately the people that
you're talking about have more of a
point than they should which is this is
madness
right so I don't want them to have a
point I don't want a civil war what I
want is for people to sober up and stop
behaving in this way but I also having
seen a mini version of this know better
right so I would put on your radar if
you're not thinking about it yet the
coincidence of shut down stem traveling
with this religious belief system that
you and I both see is extremely
important there is a reason that this
religious movement that we see in our
streets is also talking about shutting
down stem and we saw this all in
miniature at Evergreen they came after
stem also there was a reason that it was
me they came after they went after my
students too in fact one of my
mixed-race student woman whose mother's
afro-caribbean was actually confronted
by the rioters and accused of race
trading for being a science student so
this anti science belief system is
infused into this critical race theory
religion that we see mm-hmm protesting
and rioting and so the threat that that
poses to our ability even if you had
this documentary that you're talking
about it would be I don't know what the
can is their documentary burning they
will be burning right and effectively it
will only reach those who already in
some sense know better so I'm I'm just
watching this thing take over people who
should know better and so that says
something about the mechanism of action
the arguments that are being deployed
are really low quality but the mechanism
of action is really powerful the
strategy is very very strong it's a
smart strategy so I don't know where
that leaves us
now as to your point about it can't be
podcasts I agree with you
I've increasingly started to wonder if
one of the problems that we face is that
the people who should be in a leadership
position people who could say something
could shut down the bad arguments and
substitutes that earlier and that those
people are I would say trapped in the
gig economy and they don't have the
power of leaders because everybody can
click away they don't you know a leader
can tell you something you don't want to
know but you need to know somebody who
you know you're deciding to watch them
and as soon as they start saying things
that you don't like you go find somebody
who says stuff you like better that's
not a leadership position and so I
wonder if part of what's taking place is
that the transformation of the way we
interact with each other has ruined the
concept of leadership and a leaderless
movement is a dangerous movement because
it's inherently going to subscribe to
pleasant fantasies utopia among them you
know you're scaring me but I want to
venture this if what we're really seeing
is a pendulum shift like on the campuses
like this is not remotely to minimize
what happened to you but when that
happened to you there were many of us
including you who were thinking and I
understand what you're saying about the
whole attitude towards stem and how
insidious that could be but we were
thinking is this college is this what
it's going to be to be at a university
from now on and as I've been observing
lately in the historical sense that was
actually only a few years in the mid
teens that was kind of a fashion and
watch it happened tomorrow somewhere but
you notice there's a cluster of events
like that and then it kind of stopped
and I think it was partly because of the
pushback against it from a lot of
sensible people it's not that I think
anybody was reading an op-ed in The
Chronicle of Higher Education and
decided not to do with it but I'm not
sure how these things happen but Society
turned against people getting beat up
when they come to speak on a campus and
in this case if that happens after about
three years and we've got about three
years to wait this out
if that happens the good thing that will
have come out of it is that I think it
has been resoundingly proven that people
like Tallahassee Coates are wrong
in their sense that America is this
place that's utterly united against
black people on all levels and that
nothing will ever happen because all you
have to do is look at the color of a lot
of those crowds to see that there's a
certain kind of white person and it's
not only you know an tyfa it's not only
college students it's a lot of people
who have really changed and made this
country a different place than it was
even 25 years ago which to me feels like
five minutes ago maybe that'll be the
result but that that could only have
happened you get into kind of dime-store
eagle here with all of this craziness
going on right now that might not be
what happens that we might be at a
particular turning point in which case
you are the wise one right now and I'm
the one who's assuming that Hitler will
go away I'm just hoping that I'm making
some kind of sense can we agree that we
are both rooting for you to be right I
mean so strongly here's here's my
concern I also thought that we were
actually turning the tide on college
campuses and you know there's some
reason to think that what happened at
Reed for example is very different than
Evergreen even if it started out similar
but I actually think something else
explains the fact that this has died
down on college campuses and it's less
helpful which is that in some sense this
is a millennial delusion and I don't
mean it's all Millennials my wife and I
you know Heather we taught mostly
Millennials for the entire time we were
teaching and have a great many
millennial friends so we know there are
lots of people in that generation who
can think very carefully but there is
also a kind of tendency to embrace this
mode of thinking that has now left
college and it's now inside of all these
other institutions and so the fact that
we are seeing the same battle that we
saw at Evergreen now apparently
unfolding inside the New York Times and
every other journalistic apparatus
that's to me not a hopeful sign because
it means that now we're not dealing with
the the toy version we're dealing with
this with all of the stuff on which we
depend
and that's not a it's not a helpful
thought you know Brett I think this is
fun I think we should we should do a
part two and we should do a part two
when I'm in my home and there's nobody
in it and the shower doesn't need to be
fixed because no you're really making me
think about these things and the thing
though is that college generations
reproduce themselves and I get the idea
that the people from 10 minutes ago
who were hollering on campuses are now
interns of the New York Times or
something like that but wouldn't you
expect that succeeding freshman classes
would have kept doing the same thing
because I pass it on one to another what
if it was or if it was just one three or
four year cohort who then went and
carried it somewhere else in a way
that's good news because it would mean
that these people will just keep getting
older and older and their current jobs
and then they'll become these graying
people who are you know strangely angry
but then there's this whole generation
below them that aren't it seems to me
that usually these things are passed on
to the people who are slightly younger
and somehow that didn't happen and it
may be just I'm speaking from Columbia
where for mysterious reasons nothing
like that ever really happened so I made
me feel more sanguine because protests
at Columbia are small and brief as
opposed to there having ever been
anything that made the news other than
the controversal kibbutz is controversy
the Mattress controversy and that's a
really very different set of issues than
what we're talking about here although
there's a there's an intersection but I
don't know I
I hope I'm right too only because it
would be frightening for this country to
be taken over by people who refuse to
reason and don't know that that's what
they're doing they don't know they're
refusing the reason they think that
there are certain issues upon which
there can be no reasoning and you
literally can't talk to them they cannot
be reasoned with and put them in
positions of power and next thing you
know the country does start to disappear
that is that is a very frightening
prospect yeah it's it's very frightening
I don't think we can stand even a brief
period in which this modality rules I
don't think it will happen it's hard for
me to conceive of how it would last long
enough but my concern is what it
destruct disrupts in the meantime so I
don't know again I am definitely rooting
for you to be right but I I do think we
at least need to consider the
possibility that what we are seeing is
demographic its aging into power and
that that has frightening implications
if we don't get around it and I guess
the two last points would be it does
raise a question about how we can reboot
leadership so that there is something
that can be reasoned with there is
someone on the other side who's ready to
to have the discussion about what is
actually taking place and what an actual
remedy might sound like rather than the
narrative that's being deployed which is
so inaccurate that any remedy to it is
bound to backfire and I've watched
leaders recruited even recently who
clearly part of why they were recruited
as leaders it's because they speak this
new language and these are leaders who
have no idea that speaking a language
but and I'll bet the people who vetted
them weren't thinking consciously of
what they were vetting the people for
but a person wouldn't have made it
through who didn't have the ability to
stop reasoning when it came to issues of
race that's scary to see and I'm
thinking about people who are in their
40s who were recruited in this way
they're not kids so yeah I know what you
mean it's it's creepy it's creepy stuff
and it's why I'm going a book I am doing
a book about Third Way for anti racism
it's pouring out of me as if it was
channeled from someone else I don't know
where this book is coming from but I
just realized that something is really
really wrong but a book alone isn't
isn't going to do it the question is how
to really change society you have a
working title no the title of this one
I'm waiting for whoever is channelling
this book through me to give me a title
I'm not going to coming up with titles
but it's got to have
if you have any ideas let me know it's
got to have a catchy title and the title
can't be [ __ ] all of you that one
already taken something a little more
constructive and I don't have the title
either so I like your idea of a part two
of this conversation I want to propose a
starting place okay there is something
about the origin story of the American
black population that actually is
mirrored not perfectly but it's also
mirrored with respect to Africa to
Indians to American Indians and it has
to do with the systemic disruption of
culture that took place when the US was
formed or even before and in any case I
think this fits perfectly with one of
your primary areas of study because this
is what a pidgin this is why a pidgin
emerges before a Creole and so in some
sense what I would like to discuss is
whether or not the pervasive sense that
opportunity is somehow held back from
the population of black Americans if
this is not rooted in that special
origin story and if that does not
actually point in the direction of what
real remedies might be in other words if
the frustration is real the diagnosis is
wrong but a correct diagnosis would be
helpful
maybe we can navigate our way to a I
don't know a prototype of that
discussion it's interesting that you use
the word prototype for reasons that I
will share with you when we keep going
that sounds utterly fascinating so let's
let's do that as soon as soon as
possible yeah great definitely I look
forward to it all right folks thanks so
much for joining us John thank you
John McWhorter is professor at
via hee I did not say at the top but I
will say now his podcast is lexicon
Valley yes
it's an excellent podcast on linguistic
issues primarily and in some sense in
the way they interface with modern
events as well he's written a recent
article in Collett it's quite excellent
on the George Floyd protests and
phenomenon is there anything else you
want to mention for now so yeah let's
just let's just continue this next week
or sometime soon after that and we can
explore further wonderful ah there is
one other thing I should mention John is
a very frequent guest on the Glenn show
Glenn Lowry is excellent and you guys
have done a marvelous job exploring
issues related to race in America for I
don't know how long you guys have been
doing it for thousands since we were
different people
it's definitely alright so check that
out and I look forward to talking to you
further John this has been marvelous and
let's just hope you're right let's hope
all right be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]